rick porosillo looking to back up his
fine outing against the gnats six days
ago trey turner three hits including a
home run last night
wanna pitch up he takes it the other way
balls got some carry deep and see you
later
trey turner the other way the ball is
flying in new york and the nats are
loving it who gets the ride this time
the slider lifted behind second base
guillerme trailing out and he holds the
catch going away beautifully done by
giorgi who had to go a long long way
trey turner has given
max scherzer an early lead max over the
head into the wind and the 2-2 on the
way
did he check no he didn't says home
plate umpire johnson vince conte that's
a swinging strike three on an elevated
fastball and now sharers are behind on
dom three and one ruston third two down
three and one to smith and dom walks in
the midst of the bases loaded for ramos
the numbers for ramos with the base is
full a tableresque 413 with four grand
slams in his career
got him
low zone 97
and max has to battle to almost 30
pitches so now the number nine hitter
victor roble stands in
he swings he's jammed little looper down
the left field line this is trouble if
it's fair it drops in for a base hit
kendrick around 30 is coming home to
score the throw to second and roll blaze
is out
they get robles going into second and
that will end the inning and the
nationals add a run here at the top of
the second shortstop andre jimenez
wow what a change up
87 diving two k's in a row
and the mets again
have a runner in scoring
position pause the kick the 2-2 swing
and a miss he struck him out on a cutter
down and in almost in the dirt that
retires the side fourth strikeout for
max here's dominic smith the first
baseman
line drive that's just what max and the
nats needed
right at eric thames for an unassisted
three
double play
two on one out now the number eight
hitter kurt suzuki
grounded his short a chance for two
jimenez to george on the first of the
double play that retires the side
there's your defense six four three
double play tracy menace struck out
swinging first time
jimenez drives one deep to right eaton
going back it's over his head and it's
off the fence jimenez puts the jets on
he's around second and on his way to
third eaton flings it in but jimenez
slides in safely with his second big
league triple stays back on a change up
here
and he can fly and he's out of the box
and he smells trips
now guillorme will try and get him in
middle infielder's back three balls at a
strike pitch
the army lines it toward left backing up
soto a few steps soto's there he makes
the catch tagging from third jimenez
he'll score easily so guillerme does put
the ball in play he does bring home
ximena's
down and in for the strikeout
it took him forever to get through two
innings and now max scherzer has battled
his way through five
soto hits it sharply and jimenez with a
terrific stop gets up and throws him out
unbelievable
21 years old and he is a magician with
the glove and this is a beautiful
backhand but what i find interesting is
a great play the presence of mine to
realize he's off balance and throws a
long hop to to the first baseman smith
gotten better as this game's gone on
nasty on the cutter down and in
challenge fastball he overpowered him
into a pop-up to left let him hear it
from home folks max scherzer an amazing
appearance in new york tonight all right
luis guillermo who's had a good game
tonight
aguirre may lofts one into left center
coming down is oh he lost who lost it on
the lights and it falls in guillermo
heads for second robles throw is not in
time
soto approached that ball tentatively
and it looked like he lost it on the
lights as it was coming down i think he
lost it at the last moment i think he
had it and then
he lost it the mets have left the most
men on base in the major leagues the
batting average with runners in scoring
position is in the bottom five in
baseball
he got jammed one hopper castro the turn
turner four six three
and the nats are out of the seventh
inning
he's two for three they're not busting
and he smashes a double play ball could
they do it again jimenez they double up
turner for a second time
wow daniel hudson is on
to try and preserve this one run lead
now you can overpower him with a
fastball 94 can trey get there
yes he will
fair ball when he caught it he slides
over the chalk line
and a spectacular play for the second
out
swaying and a mess
last night a blowout tonight a squeaker
and the nats win two entirely different
types of ball games